what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to my most viral YouTube
clip but before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in and let me know
what you guys would like to see me react
to next time play the clip blessing Mr
Producer most girls are objective or do
you think they think they're hotter than
they are
or do they underwrite themselves go
around personally I think it depends on
the person because growing up I'm
obviously not skinny hi everyone I'm not
skinny so growing up I was never the
beauty standard for anyone so like all
my friends were getting chatted up by
people blah blah blah and I was just the
other one you know so like I never
really thought of myself as an
attractive person like I would never
call myself anything more than a four
but now like I didn't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like I've
grown into myself and I've I've I'm
comfortable with who I am now that like
even if I you guys call me delusional or
whatever I think I'm maybe not 10 let's
not go that far but like definitely an
eight per so like
like why don't you guys lie to each
other you know your friend does not hate
and she seemed like a lovely person she
seemed like a nice girl but I'm like
lady come on you know you know you're
not Nate and if you had real eights in
front of you
would not be talking all this whether
you guys think I am or not that's got
nothing to do with her but like what is
it that took you from a four to an eight
if nothing's changed what is it that
takes loving myself and and looking in
the mirror and not being disgusted at
what I see I understand that yeah so but
that doesn't you're you're not
necessarily being objective about how
other people view you right because
isn't that what a rating really is like
what you think the vast majority like
like if I rated myself one to ten I give
myself a five I think I'm normal looking
and I just think it's based on my
results I think if I was in eight nine
or ten I would have had modeling
contracts because people in the top 20
of beauty they get they get modeling
contracts what is beauty so what what is
beauty I mean there's a lot of things
like and this is like why do we lie to
women and act like beauty isn't real
guys
we all know as women we know who's who
the prettiest girl in the room is we
know who the girls are that have similar
levels of attractive attractiveness as
us we
it is better to live in truth and in
reality and know where you fall so you
can do things to improve like you know
maybe let's let's take her for example I
give her like a two three because
because of her weight okay but she could
easily be a six if she lost weight but
instead she's like you know I'm gonna
I'm gonna love myself but you know
what's actual self-love taking care of
your body losing weight moving being
healthy that's self-love self-love isn't
eating yourself to death that's what my
auntie said this on my show once she
said obesity is slow suicide you
everyone's watching you commit suicide
and it's not loving yourself to eat
yourself to death I mean you can you can
go online and have people rate your
pictures and they rank you one to ten
that's wild and and so you can get you
can get a lot of data that says how
attractive you are in society and men
will wait you women will rate you like
every day how we look is like how we
represent ourselves it's not fun but
it's just like being honest
so
um and it's also like you can get dating
apps to like you know everyone's tender
Bumble like they have a ranking for you
behind the scenes
yeah down yeah well I trust so
um I don't understand when girls say
like I'm an eight because or sometimes I
hear girls say tongues I hear this a lot
where they say like because I love
myself and I'm like confident now but
don't you think attractiveness is based
on results
they may be but I don't care about those
results to be honest
but do you think then you're not being
objective about your how attractive you
are or how attractive anyone else might
be
um
I guess not but like yeah that stuff's
not really important to me
but I think when when someone when
someone rates somebody why why does that
have anything to do with them like if
you rate me if someone rated like
somebody or three and it's just like
okay that's that's your opinion like
it's not like it's not if one person Ray
two or three it's if we did 50 people
and 100 people and they all have similar
ratings for you you don't think that
means anything tin is not a fact it's an
opinion what do you know what I mean
well everyone's opinion then
you add up to a consensus maybe not a
fact yeah consensus yeah consensus yeah
yeah but I think
like I I have a group of friends right
and when I walk into the room with a
group of friends I know immediately
who's going to get the most attention
from the guys it's it's not shout out
Ani from college yeah always yeah the
man they loved her she's beautiful me
right I have like a friend who's like
very very attractive yeah shout out
shout out Ani hope you're doing good I
know when I walk into a room with her
like the guys talk to her first because
like girls you can kind of just feel it
but that's okay no shade no shade it's
like some girls are prettier than others
and why why do we have to be Afra like
why do we live in delusion I'm so tired
of this just wonder when I hear like and
I hear this from girls a lot like I'm a
10 I'm a 10 I'm a 10.
um if that's not like rooted in reality
because attractiveness and we can't all
be tens in order to be a 10 someone's
got to not be a 10. there's numbers
behind it whether it's just your results
in the world or your dating app data or
the like the type of guys you can get
I don't enjoy like walking into a room
and knowing everyone's gonna talk to my
friend and not me that's not fun but I
think I'd be delusional if I if I
thought if I walked into a room and I
thought
wow like they're all gonna talk to me
first I think in addition to you know I
saw a 1950s piece of dating advice and I
swear to God it was like hang around the
pretty friends so you can get their
leftovers I'm sorry women in the 1950s
were ruthless they didn't give a [ __ ]
how they got that man they didn't care
they'll take their hot friends leftovers
they don't care they're like I'm gonna
get this man I'm gonna get this back and
I don't I don't give a [ __ ] about my
pride and
[Laughter]
because nowadays that would be like
triggering no we're all equally pretty
hierarchy I was just gonna say that so
we understand that I'm a fool and Men
know this I've heard this from guys have
you guys ever done that where you have
like a hot because I've just heard this
from guys so I'm just curious where you
have a guy that you know is better
looking than you and like knows a lot of
attractive women so you spend time
around him so you can't yeah see like
man have you done that blessing yeah
yeah so like men this isn't triggering
to them they're like yeah I'll take it
he knows the hot chicks like let's go
but as women it's like triggering to us
like yo why don't they talk to me first
because there are guys that are five and
get this attention guys that are six
they get that attention seven and so on
and so forth whereas women
um I don't want to say they live in a
delusion sometimes but it's a case of
well I because I believe I'm this I am
that and I believe I'm a millionaire so
am I a millionaire no let's speak about
gender buff would let me know because
because there's a whole separate topic
where people will go oh what is gender
and then yeah yeah let's not go into
that place he's gonna get me in trouble
but I think I was just thinking beta
beta no offense no offense but like I'm
like come on we can't say men or men and
women around I let it go I let it go on
the show I do think that women also
understand the hierarchy it's just like
in this day and age because see that's
what she's saying like we know we know
deep down we've been exposed to what men
want we kind of understand like oh okay
that's not what men want but I don't
care because I'm not I'm never gonna be
that you know you could
with some diet and exercise you
absolutely could be what men want
without
money
and and clout shall I say what do you
guys think men want
Kim Kardashian body whoa let's ask y'all
that's a good question I should ask that
on the show again what do you think Ben
wants yeah yeah I want to hear because
you said like you think that girls
understand what men want so I want to go
like one by one and
do you think what do you think men want
sorry
I couldn't tell you because
I feel like
again I've never been in a relationship
but I've chatted to quite a few guys and
it seems like it's not even that I don't
live up to their standards I feel like
I'm never what they want and I'm like is
it looks okay apparently I checked that
box but they still don't want me it's a
personality yeah you're cool your Vibes
but I don't want a wife you like I don't
I don't get it you say you want
personality but you still go and try and
treat a girl like a hoe and I know this
is not all guys I understand that and
maybe this is just the guys I attract I
don't know what I'm doing but okay cool
okay but do you see the way she talks
there's a lot more humility in that and
saying you know I I don't know what I'm
doing wrong like she doesn't blame the
world at least she takes ownership and
is like yeah something's I I don't know
what men want she doesn't pretend to
know everything but I just feel like
maybe society as a whole not everyone
we do care a lot about looks and I think
that is a lot about like the fact it's
just it's very superficial I think a lot
of guys are very superficial again not
all I actually think women are more
superficial because if you look at
dating app data women only swipe right
like five percent of the time menswear
50 they're like ah hot they're good
enough ah not obese good enough guys
okay A little obese good enough pretty
face but maybe a certain kind of guys
they just care more about looks could I
give you some advice in regards to like
dealing with a guy like actually guys
tell me if you think this guy gave good
advice on the show I'm not sure where
you stand with him where he's saying
like he might have you but he's not
willing to commit to you or he might you
know take you out on dates or you might
cook dinner for him or you you might
take him on dates you know whatever it
is yeah but there's no commitment
there's no
would you like to meet my dad bang what
if you don't have anything okay fair
enough but would you like to meet my
family would you like to meet my brother
would you like to meet my mum
as soon as you take it there I'm sorry
but there's an immediate decision that
that partner has to make I'm actually
serious about this do I want to am I I
invested in this person enough to
actually engage with their family what
do you guys think good advice bad advice
I know what blessing is thinking
so and honestly from the beginning would
you meet someone's dad that you weren't
serious about now anymore
blessing knows a guy that does that Mr
Producer
most of the time they don't want a
plus-sized girl because that was the
only girl that said something that was
facts that's true either they're afraid
or I'm there she started going left
They're Not Afraid
now we just co-signed nonsense Not
Afraid not attracted to
um or if they do they only want to be
low-key about it they don't want to seen
in public yeah yeah well if they don't
want people to know that they're that
they're like talking to you or or trying
to do a thing with you
but most of the the guy friends that
I've had usually want like girls
definitely big bum it's always a big bum
always always always and then but the
thing is most of the time I'm curious
pick one butter boobs boobs okay it's
like 50 50. one the the big bum but it's
very stereotypical
things
yeah The Hourglass yeah they want the
the nice boom like figure so I want to
hear from the guys
um what do you guys what do y'all want
if you guys wanted to get married what
would you look for in a wife
I'm gonna get hate for this but
submissiveness oh that's okay oh okay
that's fine
for me
um look I'm I'm a Muslim I'm I I may not
be religious but I try to be submission
isn't the word that I tend to use you
like if a woman is submissive to God
then she will do her Duty as a wife yeah
what I require from a wife is fun if
there's one word is cooperativeness what
does that mean that you have a wife a
partner that is gonna ride or die with
you towards the same goal towards the
same end yeah that is the fundamental
quality that I require from a woman
beautiful fade facts Beauty will fade
no all the time look there are some 50
year old women out there that still got
a God bless them yeah yeah all right
right sure but listen cooperativeness
like are you going to be holding it down
you know whilst I'm struggling at work
or
you know if there's kids at home crying
and screaming are you gonna give up easy
what kind of character do you have do
you have resilience do you have like the
ability to give me peace when I need it
are you gonna be able to take care of
things
as I need you to when I need you to yeah
like
I'm not saying have a woman like at the
end of a whip yo do this for me do that
for me no no no the main thing I think
is just that fundamental cooperativeness
that we agree towards the same similar
goal or the same goal and that we're
both see like men really aren't that
picky he didn't say she has to have a
perfect body she didn't say he didn't
say she has to have a perfect face they
just you just need to be above their
minimum level of attractiveness not that
they would sleep with it they'd be seen
in public with be cooperative supportive
not talk too much make a sandwich here
and there like men really aren't that
picky gone in for that together now we
might have separate roles when gunning
for that same goal yeah but the goal is
the same and if she's on board that's it
yeah what about you
um you said a lot of things as well so
but like just to add on to what you guys
said I I just want peace I want someone
that can bring me peace when I come back
from the world
um that I'm having to fight in order to
kind of bring something to the table
um from your answers ladies it sounded
like you girls didn't really know what
men want you see the look at shark on
their faces they're like what I didn't
say anything fair enough fair enough
well so um like that would more indicate
you don't know what men want if when I
ask you the question you say nothing
not to be fair they they answered so and
then it continued
hey all right but yeah it it sounds like
you have an indication of what you think
men want and you're doing the things
that you think
men want and then you're not getting the
results except of what you want
so that's my most viral YouTube video
um I thought that was a very
entertaining video I really liked it I
don't miss that apartment though oh my
God I don't miss it that apartment was
so hot and that was this summer so every
shot I mean it gets hot in here too
shout out to the UK you guys don't have
air conditioning
um but that one was really bad but those
girls are actually so sweet and nice and
the thing is it's just crazy how like
even beautiful women have no idea what
men want and I think it's because just
men haven't had standards for a really
long time and they haven't required much
from women but we're gonna change that
guys let's end the simp epidemic let me
know in the comments how you're gonna
help end the simp epidemic like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I will talk to you next time
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible